but we began with chief White House
correspondent John Roberts with the
breaking news president Trump is losing
hope
but this White House says they knew it
was coming good evening John well I
think he's losing hope in the form of a
person not necessarily in the form of an
idea you mentioned one of the people
closest to the president I would say
that other than the president's
immediate family of a Melania Ivanka and
Jared Kushner hope is probably the
person who's been closest to him has
been literally at his side for the past
three years working 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year
she was embroiled in controversy not of
her own making recently when the man
that she was dating Rob Porter was to
come to allegations of domestic abuse
and was told to leave the White House
she testified yesterday for some ten
hours before the House Intelligence
Committee about what she knew about
potential collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia in that testimony
she admitted to at times telling quote
white lies on behalf of the president
though she did say under questioning
that none of those things had any kind
of bearing on the Russia investigation
at least no substantive bearing on the
Russia investigation some statements
from the White House one of them from
hope Hicks herself saying quote there
are no words to adequately express my
gratitude to President Trump
I wish the president and his
administration the very best as he
continues to lead our country from the
president hope isn't is outstanding and
has done great work for the last three
years she is as smart and as thoughtful
as they come a truly great person I will
miss having her by my side but when she
approached me about pursuing other
opportunities I totally understood I am
sure we will work together in the future
White House officials say that she has
been thinking about leaving the White
House for some time she has been working
at a breakneck pace for longer than most
people would be able to she will also
stay here at the White House for maybe
the next few weeks breath that her
departure is not immediate but it is
imminent Brett John stand by if you
would catherine herridge here you know
the White House is insisting Catherine
that this does not have to do with that
testimony up on Capitol Hill it was 9
hours of questioning and it comes
obviously after
she talked to special councilor Muller
and his team recently for a lot of
questioning as well one of my contacts
has been working closely with the White
House on the Russia investigations
pointed out then his opinion hope Hicks
has really been beaten up pretty badly
by the whole process and not in any
reasonable way what he pointed to was
not only the interview with the Special
Counsel rubber Muller's team but also an
interview with the Senate Intelligence
Committee and then most recently the
House Intelligence Committee behind
closed doors for nine hours where she
answered questions getting into a lot of
specifics but individuals and meetings
during the campaign and then also the
transition period here's our Republicans
and Democrats responded after the
session Catherine what about the manna
fort situation there's some news about
that well Paul Manafort was in a DC
Federal Court this morning in Washington
and he was responding to a superseding
indictment an additional five counts he
pled not guilty but it was his first
court appearance since his business
partner Rick gates got that guilty
agreement or plea agreement rather with
the special counsel where he's pledged
full cooperation
a man of courts now looking at a trial
date in September and he was admonished
by the federal judge for releasing a
statement at the end of last week where
he seemed to chide gates for not being
in the fight for the long term and being
in it to prove their innocence there is
basically a gag order from that court
right now for both sides but manna forts
team says they're going to contest it
Brett thanks Catherine John another
question to you about the turnover in
this administration there has been a lot
of it if you look at all of the people
who have left in the first 13 months of
this president's time in office it is
quite a few thoughts from this White
House about that turnover and perhaps
you know this was his closest his
confidant the person who was with him
for the longest okay in many ways his
right-hand man I mean we know about the
turnover here at the White House and
there's some sure that's happening as we
speak now there are a number of people
who are transitioning out of the White
House but if you look just specifically
at this position of communications
director it has probably been the
position with the greatest chair and
don't forget Sean Spicer
the in that was the first communications
director because they really couldn't
find a communications director so he was
playing the dual role of press secretary
and comms director then they brought in
Dan dub key who lasted for a couple of
months and then Spicer was named
communications director again and then
Anthony scaramouche II was brought in
for a period of eleven days and then
hope Hicks was named the communications
director I'm told that the hope hits
really wanted to she wanted to leave and
she'd been thinking about it for some
time she really wanted to get this
testimony before the House Intelligence
Committee out of the way before she made
the decision to leave and according to
sources she told the president today
that she had made the final decision to
go what's unclear in all of this Pratt
will continue to try to dig to get more
information is how much did her White
Lies comment play into her leaving we
don't know what the president's reaction
was to the news that she had said that
we don't know if if people thought that
maybe after that there was a little bit
of a credibility problem but we'll
continue to shake the bushes around here
to find out if that played into it at
all or if he had just simply decided
after three years of running at this
breakneck pace it was time to go and
pursue opportunities outside of the
White House right all right john roberts
catherine herridge thank you